good
morning representative costable would
you lead us in the pledge
please Al to the FL of the United States
ofer and to the repic for it stands one
nation under God indivisible with Li and
for all thank you very
much I'm opening the executive session
um going with uh House Bill 1518 and
recognize representative wall for a
motion thank you Mr chairman and I
apologize for the voice again um on
House Bill
158 I move that we
itl uh representative wall boes itl is
there second seconded by
representative oh man brain cramp pay
thank you payer thank you you are close
you were almost called montio for a
second there um do you want to speak uh
yes uh representative wall uh would you
like to your motion or let someone else
do it and save your voice thank you I'll
be very brief um the sponsor did not
show up for this bill and there are
times when we've had a bill when we have
uh held it over and waited for a sponsor
to come in the sponsor to the best of my
knowledge is aware that this bill is not
going to pass
and the issue is the fact that the
Ethics Committee is also against this
which some people may find problematic
but we have very carefully chosen Meers
members of the Ethics Committee the top
leadership in the House and Senate
appoint different members and the way
the committee is set up we have one
Democrat from the house and the Senate
one republican from the house and the
Senate and we have um excuse me the
three other public members are chosen by
the Senate President the house and
jointly together and we have a system
that works um I heard this morning that
there have been complaints against us
the Ethics Committee has never had a
complaint there are times we have in
terms of our processes there are times
we have to go into nonpublic sessions
and that's by law and that information
is not made public we then come out of
non-public sessions and we say what the
decision is and if anyone has any
concerns or anything they can speak up
that has not happened um I'm just saying
it's not broken we don't need to fix it
thank
you thank you representative wall uh
further discussion representative
Reed by way before you speak um I want
to thank everyone who come came in and
uh helped us out today U as substitutes
I appreciate your help representative
Reed sorry for that no thank you Mr
chair um so I just conferred with the
Bill's Prime sponsor who was under the
understanding that she would receive
another hearing and was that it was not
going to be killed so that piece of
information um is not accurate according
to her I will say that um I I do think
the Ethics Committee needs um reform
because there's been multiple situations
that um we neither have rules but also
the Ethics Committee hasn't acted on
like times many many times where members
have voted on issues where they are
personally uh financially
um tied to the issue and yet do not
recuse themselves other issues I won't
go into because I know that those are
confidential but um I don't I personally
I don't think this bill as written will
affect that but I would prefer to see
this interim studied um because I do
think in the long term we need to reform
the Ethics Committee and the fact that
the Ethics Committee is Weighing on
regulating itself in and of itself is a
problem I
think thank you representative Reed uh
further
discussion so let me just um
clarify um something that was said
um uh the prime sponsor did not um did
not show up I think we had rep costol
introduced the bill right um I heard
from um the prime
sponsor the day we were the day before
we were going to execute last week week
um and and at that time we had a hallway
conversation and I suggested to her that
we would still be executing her bill
today I had moved it from that week to
today and that um if she were here I
would give her U five minutes before we
exacted it um there was there was no
promise given of another hearing it was
uh I would let her speak before before
we exec it
um I I don't see her here so
that's uh excuse representative Reed I
appreciate the clarification I didn't
mean to say that what she had said was
accurate only that I was uh countering
the idea that the prime sponsor was okay
with killing the bill because I just
talked to her and that was not her
understanding whether her understanding
was correct or not I don't know but I'm
just letting you know that that is not
the understanding of the Prime sponsor
thank you I'll pass her note in Jim um
any further
conversations any discussion on this
bill seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the rooll the motion is itl on
House Bill
1518 thank you Mr chair itl on
1518 uh Vice chair Sheen yes
representative costal yes the clerk
votes yes representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tyy yes representative
sers yes representative wall yes
representative
Brennan yes representative
turot yes representative
Richards no she's not here so we don't
and we don't have a sub for rep
Richards oh I'm sorry I missed that okay
uh representative
Lane yes yes representative Sebert
yes representative Reed
no representative payer yes and Mr chair
yes 14
yay one nay I guess two Nays considering
or no I'm I'm unsure how yeah all right
one nay
sorry I threw me off okay 14 14 y one
uh I heard consent uh any objection no
okay no objection um Minority
Report
yes oh that's right
sorry um I'm not
okay uh so we'll close the exec session
on
1518 um we'll let the clerk reset and
then we'll be taking up
hr25 the sponsor and I'm like oh it's
right
here just so I don't forget it later uh
it would be great if blurs uh could be
received by either myself or
representative Sheen by noon
tomorrow electronically or paper good by
me okay I'm
ready
you okay I'll open the executive session
on um
hr25 uh recognize representative mcarter
for a
motion thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion for interim study for
hr25 representative mcara moves interim
study seconded by representative
wall
um representative mcarter would you like
to discuss your motion I would thank you
Mr chair um we've uh come upon some um
additional information recently that I
think uh Warren's further work on this
bill as opposed to um bringing it to the
house floor at this time so I'm
requesting some more time to work on
that
thank you representative uh further
discussion representative wall thank you
I second that because it's a very
important issue uh we need to look into
it further we have not had the time to
do that I think in this committee when
we do interim study we really do interim
study thank
you thank you representative wall um
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair I just want to note out as far as
I think the is a great idea because it
will actually weed out uh the positiv
and negative of the of the HR that was
presented even though it wasn't supposed
to be an HR that's how it ended up the
other part is is we all know words
matter all right and we that's why I
think the study is going to help us out
because between rules rsas
Constitution we have some words in there
that are conflicting and I think that
study will actually clear that up
thank you representative sers uh further
conversation
discussion I'll just make one comment um
it's clear that we have an ongoing legal
situation with the issues that erased in
this um house
resolution uh it would seem logical to
me um and why I will vote Yes for the
interim study that um that that will
give us time for for um the findings
from the New Hampshire Supreme Court um
to be heard and um and as representative
wall said earlier we do uh in this
committee uh treat interim study as a
true interim study um so we would be
able to have the information from the
Supreme Court um at that
time uh further conversation
representative s Mr chair I was just
wondering if um it could be our
committee doing the study do you know
that for
sure if if if we if we interim study it
we study
it yes I do know
that and you'll be chairing
it um further further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on interim study
on
hr25 thank thank you Mr chair interim
study for hr25 vice chair Shen yes
Michael uh representative costable yes
clerk votes yes representative Pearson
yes representative mcarter yes
representative Tierney yes
representative cers yes representative
wall yes representative Brennan yes
representative
turot yes representative Richard's not
here representative Lane sorry yes
representative
Sebert yes representative Reed yes and
representative payer yes and last but
not least chair yeah yes all right
unanimous two
three 15 yay thank
you I'm hearing a um request for consent
I without
objection consent it is
Blur by tomorrow thank you committee
report by
tomorrow yes um I'll close the executive
session on
hr25 uh give the clerk a minute or two
to reset and then we'll go on to
hr29
open the executive session on house uh
resolution 29 um recognize
representative Pearson for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move on itl on
house resolution 29 representative
Pearson moves uh itl is there second
seconded by representative
mcarter uh representative Pearson would
you like to speak to your motion thank
you Mr
chair
the house
[Music]
resolution that's before us
is quite broad uh quite quite far reach
ing it involves a lot of topics that are
currently being debated in this body
through other pieces of
legislation uh one of the items
specifically of concern is on line 15
where it states the
enshrining of an economic Bill of Rights
in the New Hampshire Constitution that
is this is certainly not the vessel to
do something like
that so I find the the the
complications the the
broad topics are are current tackling of
certain issues in that problematic line
to be more than justification for an itl
motion thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Pearson further
discussion representative
Reed thank you Mr chair I mean I agree
with representative Pearson that it is
quite Broad and I'm not sure that this
is the correct vessel because if you're
going to enshrine Something in the
Constitution seems like it would be a
cacr so I I agree with all that however
when I read this I like all of these
things I think it's good it is Broad it
is Broad but they're all good things
that we should all have and so I would
prefer to see an interim study to talk
about and if it needs to be narrowed it
needs to be narrowed but you know things
like pollution-free water and safe
housing those things I think in an
Equitable justice system I think those
things are are good and we should
enshrine them in the Constitution so I
think it's worth discussing over uh an
interim study and um and coming up with
perhaps slightly narrower language so I
would support interim study thank you
representative Reed represent cable
thank you Mr chair um yeah I want to I
don't want to get too down into the we
on this but um one of the you know you
can't really disagree with most of these
but it really becomes on what is the
solution which is why you would really
need specific bills to Target specific
things because there's different we'll
we'll we'll agree on it but we'll have
different um Avenues to get there and I
think that's where the debate should
happen is on the actual Solutions but
getting right to the HR one of the
problems I had um I had worked on um C
few years ago on a lot of energy bills
and with the governor's office we on a
task force and put forward a bunch of
bills um and one of the the tenants in
this this was reliable and green um
energy um
and factually speaking those are
opposite you can the green energy right
now is unreliable um so while it sounds
good to say in practice it's it's it's
an impossibility because green energy
right now is inherently
unreliable um so while these
conversations need to be had it's not
it's not um necess neily the the place
to do it thank you Mr chair thank you
rep Constable um further
discussion representative Reed thank you
again Mr chair I mean uh again I I
prefer interm study because I do agree
that this is a bit broad um I mean the
representative I can debate separately
as it's not in in in like immediately
gerain to debate how reliable green
energy is but I am the chair of my
energy and environment Committee in my
town and I'm the uh National caucus of
environmental legislators State lead so
I can I I'm happy to have that debate
privately but I I do agree we can narrow
this narrow this down but having a Bill
of Rights that is kind of like a
onot constitutional change is completely
within precedent first of all our
federal Bill of Rights we got 10 of them
in one shot in fact Madison had to
promise that Bill of Rights when he was
trying to sell the Constitution just to
get the con constitution ratified um New
Hampshire took the lead on that and said
we're going to put our Bill of Rights
front and center in our in our
constitution so it's the very first
thing so having a Bill of Rights that
enumerates several things is completely
within precedent um and we can debate
like how broad the language is and can
it be narrowed but having the idea that
in this state every person will be
guaranteed a certain basic quality of
life um as a as a effect of us having
those values I think that's a debate
worth having and so again I would vote
down the inter study and I vote down the
itl and vote for interim
study thank you representative Reed uh
representative sers thank you Mr chair I
I look at these resolutions that it's
when we do a house resolution I would
think we'd have the majority not just
51% but I mean I would think would have
like 70 80 or 90% voting for I don't see
that happening with this HR at this
point
um a lot in there is is good and it's
it's makes sense to have and I think we
do it every day now anyway but I at the
same time I think we want to make sure
we're get Buy in from as many as
possible especially when it's a house
resolution thank you representative sers
uh representative wall thank you and I'm
sorry but I really can't say much but
I'm going to support the people who want
interm Study because there's enough
question and concern
that it deserves further discussion and
therefore I will support those who want
in term
sty thank you representative wall
forther
discussion oh representative
Reed um once again the interim study the
purpose of it I I agree that it
shouldn't be an HR it should be a cacr
and We Know How likely cacs are to pass
anyway but um the purpose of an inter
study is to see about recommending what
language we might recommend for future
legislation so I think this committee
could narrow the language find out
language that everyone agrees on and
recommend a cacr in the future so I
think an inter stud is quite
appropriate thank you representative
Reed um further
discussion Mr chairman representative
wall I am so sorry uh representative re
just brought up a very important point
that oftentimes we'll have a bill that
simply deserves further discussion and
we bring parties together and get
problems resolved and we don't need a
law but in this particular instance it's
important to have further discussion in
case there are laws that people feel we
need to have um and further legislation
developed for so I I will support interm
study as I said Thank
you thank you representative wall
further
discussion I will just say
um for those that are new to this
process um interim
study in the second year in an election
year um makes it kind of difficult and
what we're ultimately going to end up
with is either a vote on whether the
legislation um
deserves or or whether the HR um
deserves further legislation or not um
it's it's not generally a place where
you going to end up bringing in more
legislation it's it's more just does it
deserve further legislation or not um it
will be a discussion I will grant you
that um that's what we're doing in
interim study um
but as far as um the outcome of of
fixing legislation Andor coming up with
solutions that can be done outside of
interim study with with any kind of an
ad hoc meeting and in fact I think they
had actually mentioned um in the
conversation with the prime sponsor and
the
testimony I think that's what she said
she was looking for um was the ability
to have um a caucus um either create a
caucus but have a
discussion it it seems to me um that can
be done regardless of the outcome of
this uh vote so
um I will be supporting the in uh the
itl motion um One Last Time
representative Reed thank you so much
for your graciousness Mr chair um I just
wanted to I think there may have been a
misspeaking there because interim study
is always a secondy year emotion um it's
not ever a first year motion uh retain
is the first year motion and interim
study is the second year motion which
always happens in an election year so
that's just the nature of interim study
always um so I just wanted to clarify
that little
point
further discussion sorry about
that um seeing none uh I will ask the
clerk to call the roll uh motion is in
uh is uh itl on
hr29 okay thank you Mr chair on hr29 itl
uh rep shean yes representative costable
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative mcarter yes
representative tney yes representative
sers yes representative wall no
representative
Brennan no representative turot
yes representative
Lane no representative
Sebert no representative Reed no
representative payer no and the chair
yes
n yay 6 nay motion
carries uh I will uh the final vote was
96 yep um I'm
assuming um Minority Report Minority
Report um no um you can't no
substitutes um
sorry about that um you will let me know
who's writing The Minority Report if
there is
one you will let me know it needs still
be here by tomorrow noon
time
um and uh representative Pearson I think
you've already provided me the the
report who thank you um closing the
exact session on
hr29 give us a minute to reset and we'll
be on to um host Bill
1343 who is second on
that
okay um opening the exact session on
House Bill
1343 Rec recognize representative Hopson
for a motion thank you Mr chair I'd like
to move itl for HB
1343 representative Hobson moves itl in
expedient to legislate on 1343 is their
second seconded by representative
mcarter representative Hopson would you
like to speak to your motion yes I would
uh
so I uh under this
legislation um Power of the body would
be delegated to four people and under
the New Hampshire Constitution the
supreme legislative Authority is vested
in the House of Representatives and the
Senate each having a negative on the
other the state constitution provides
that neither the House of Representative
nor the Senate May act in the absence of
a specified
quorum uh the requirement that the
legislative authority of the government
may be exercised only by a quorum of the
two bodies of the general
court part two article two Article
Five thank you thank you representative
Hobson further
discussion representa
pay your light is on um and so is
J thought you were signaling me somehow
sending up the B signal um further
discussion um I would just point out um
well maybe one or two things actually I
don't need to um that's fine we will
leave it as uh as the um discussion that
representative Hobson had um I will ask
clerk to call the role on House Bill
1343 the motion is inexpedient to
legislate
thank you Mr chair on the motion of itl
for
1343 representative shien yes
representative
costable
yes clerk votes yes representative
Pearson yes representative mcarter yes
representative tney yes representative
sers yes representative wall yes
representative
cherot yes representative
Richards oh
sorry I didn't have time to cross her
name out representative Lane yes
representative
cber yes representative Reed yes
represent prer yes and Mr chair yes okay
you I think that was
15 yay representative Pearson moves
consent anyone else uh object seeing
none that will be on
consent close the hearing uh the exact
session on House Bill
1343 um we be opening the hearing uh
yeah the exact session on uh 1388 in
just a
minute
all right I'm opening the executive
session on House Bill
1388 um recognized representative shien
for a
motion yes I move um ought to pass our
representative Sheen moves ought to pass
is there a
second I'm
sorry representative wall seconds um
bill is open to further
Amendment representative
Shen yes uh I move amendment number 2024
d694
representative Sheen moves
Amendment something something something
something something something repeat
um right two different I'm going I'm
going to move amendment number 2024
d694 okay representative moves uh
2024 69
4H um is there a
second seconded by representative
mcarter uh representen would you like to
discuss the amendment yes I'd like to
discuss it and I defer to the
chair I have to try that that's that's
very well done
um what you have in front of you is um
is a replace all um after section two um
so it is
um this
is a an amendment that's going to codify
um uh recusals for conflicts of interest
um for those of you that don't know the
history on this uh I think this is the
third year that um we've had uh similar
legislation before us
um each year started by the chair of the
Ethics Committee um they have been
asking for us to have in statute um
recusal which didn't up until now exist
in our uh in our vernacular in our
ethics book which as you'll see has a
lot of writing on it from my end um we
have tried uh a number of times we have
um uh come up up with Solutions
ourselves out of this committee uh only
to um have uh sought from us changes to
the language from the Ethics Committee
um we've taken it some to the floor and
had them taed or Ted them ourselves
because other information came up um
this amendment um is a collaboration of
uh the Ethics Committee and this
committee
and um I think represents our best
opportunity to um to bring a unified
Bill to the Senate um after it passes
the house um my understanding is there's
another piece of legislation that's
coming back to us so we're not done with
this um from the Senate I don't know if
it'll pass there but um we may not be
out of the woods completely um or we may
be ending to to in a committee of
conference to reconcile the two um what
this does is um is provide two
categories for conflict of interest um
one is a financial interest um which is
defined on line
11 and a nonfinancial interest which is
16 um it also provides exclusions for
recusal um and the primary one being
anything that um comes as the
preparation review approval or
disapproval of the state budget or any
General Revenue
legislation um it also has a um an
exclusion for anyone that um has an
incidence of ownership as most of us do
through some kind of a retirement plan
um in Securities Andor if you are on a
uh a board board um or an officer of uh
or ownership less than 5% of the total
out actually I think that should be 1%
of the total does the other one say
1% um that needs to be looked at
um with that uh conflict of interest
um would refer to um anyone the
legislator a member of the legislator's
House hold um that was has been a
sticking point in the past um but we've
settled on that
language
and I don't
think there is anything else
um I'm happy to uh to have questions um
if there are any um or further
discussion on uh Amendment uh 2024
0694 representative
Reed thank you Mr chair thank you to the
entire committee on which I am but a sub
for taking up this issue um I know it to
be an important issue because for
example we've had multiple bills
regarding landlords and there are 43
members of the house because I asked I
asked Rich Lambert to to pull the
information
that receive a significant amount of
their income from being a landlord and
yet almost none of them have uh declared
a conflict of interest and recuse
themselves from voting so that's that's
just one of many many examples and I
think it's very important this be taken
up I can't say that I'm in a position to
fully assess the the new because there's
a lot of language being added in the
amendment however I will trust the work
of this committee and other people
who've worked on the amendment and hope
that through our process it will'll get
to the correct
language thank you representative Reed I
can promise you that there's been much
discussion on on this single piece of
paper um representative wall you
have well I I'm sorry to bother you with
this um question was brought to my
attention what if someone is a treasurer
for a town how does this work with that
or if someone's working on a Town budget
how does this work with
the um anyone find it ironic that
someone sitting on the Ethics Committee
asks me that question um so it would
seem to me um that uh that this
specifically speaks to budgetary
questions as an exemption um I would
think um and again this is my
understanding of the amendment
um I would think that would be something
that we certainly should clarify um with
eth with the Ethics Committee and um uh
how they would handle um
municipalities um and their and their
location rather than me proclaiming what
what would happen with it now um is that
something that I will I will turn that
around to a question is that something
that um you have spoken with the members
of the Ethics Committee with over for
some time now as you're aware the Ethics
Committee has really struggled with this
and um of course we have to declare if
any one of us is involved with a budget
process in a town or some other
organization dealing with money and an
issue comes before the
legislature um we have to declare that
and my personal belief is we should
recuse if we have a direct impact from
the issue that's before the legislature
and it affects the issues on which we're
working on locally thank
you thank you representative wall um yes
representative Lane thank you for
letting me um comment as a sub
um would it then follow that whatever
budget then comes before the town if
someone is a city counselor or a select
person
are they going to have to be
refused sorry I'm a lawyer I'm not sorry
I'm a lawyer but I'm I'm picky I'm
picky thank you th this amendment and
this legislation involves
legislators so I I don't see how this
addresses conflicts within uh sub
political subdivisions at all unless I'm
missing it but this is the word legisl
legislator occurs multiple almost in
every
paragraph yeah I I think it would be a
non-financial personal interest that's
where it's coming in at least the way I
would read this not not a not a um not
an income related one I
agree then perhaps I misunderstood what
you said I thought you were referring to
a conflict between two local
positions not not a legislative position
no I was just uh representative Lane
sorry thank you I was commenting on
representative
walls uh and about the discussion about
a Treasurer and so if the treasurer is
going to be um held to have a conflict
of interest does it not then extend to
the select person or the city council
whatever form of of government they have
would that conflict of interest not
extend to them as well because they're
voting on that budget and they so that
that was my question
okay thank you representative Lane
representative thank you I think where
represented L was going is if that
Treasurer or the person who sits on the
council or board to select me or
whatever is also a legislator and
there's an issue before us I think
that's where you're coming from is that
correct thank you so let me say that um
no don't be sorry um this is what this
is all about um so I would say um the
disclosure for um the occupation that
the legislator had as a bank president
um that would still be the same that you
would still um notify that at the
beginning of the your session on all of
those the question though is is when um
legislation comes up does that
legislation um create a conflict and and
until you you know what that legislation
is it's unclear at that point whether
there is a conflict um with their
occupation as a bank president or not um
it's it's it's an unanswerable question
at this point but they would have it
would have to be whatever if if that
came in to the point of having a
financial interest at that point or a
non-financial interest it would depend
on the context of that question um yep
follow
up um I've been on numerous nonprofit
boards and um in any time my and also I
was a partner in a law firm so I've had
to recuse myself new numerous times
because of those contacts so but those
are all disclosed but I still recuse
myself correct from voting okay correct
this this is putting that or codifying
that in
statute um I saw representative
Brennan's hand first sorry thank you um
there are a number of legislators that
serve on local boards such as select
boards and City councils would it not be
prudent to to um have an exclusion
specifically for locally elected offices
um given that many legislators are um
representing their local communities in
both ways both as a legislator and a
local town office because there are many
issues that come before this body that
deal with Municipal issues if every
person that holds both
roles um is forced to recuse
themselves we almost lose the direct
democracy that this state is quite proud
of um so I just wonder if there might be
further Amendment
necessary um to handle those situations
thank you representative Brennan um
representative
Tierney the only reason a selectman town
Treasurer anybody would have to recuse
themselves is if the bill was basically
pointing to their Town only if it is a
general bill that's going to affect all
the towns municipalities the
same they've got no extra benefit coming
to them they don't have to recuse
themselves representative Reed
representative partner thank you Mr
chair I actually agree with
representative Tierney on that um yeah
just as an asde if we paid legislators
then we wouldn't have to worry about
select boards but anyway um I I have a
question to the chair this is why I
raised my hand and that is it seems like
there's still a lot of conversation I
really want to see this committee pass
this even if I don't get to vote on it
as a sub um since it's not an early bill
would it and I think you said that the
line 26 5% needs to be changed to 1%
anyway it would it be in order to
perhaps I don't know if the chair would
entertain a subcommittee or something
and send it out later chair would not
entertain a subcommittee um
representative
Brennan thank you um because this
specifically references a non-financial
personal interest I think it would be
beneficial to the Ethics Committee to
eliminate any kind of confusion that may
come up um to in dealing with municipal
officers
um I would highly
recommend an exclusion for that
specifically thank you thank you
representative BR representative wall
well I go back to what represent your
name and represent reset if it's
specifically for your town if it's
specifically to an issue that will
affect your town it wouldn't have to say
Danbury it wouldn't have to say Handover
it wouldn't have to say that but if if
you have a budgetary issue on uh say the
budget that we're voting on um what you
would need to do then is figure out if
that directly affects your town and the
operations of your town and then I
personally think it would be appropriate
to U recuse yourself from that
particular vote because it would have a
direct impact on your town if it doesn't
have a direct impact I don't think you
need to um
represent representative
Kerney agree with most of your statement
other than the part that if it affects
your town
disproportionately to any other town
then yes you should recuse yourself if
it does not then there is no reason to
uh recuse yourself that's right excuse
me Mr chairman representative wall thank
you that's exactly right and it goes
along with everything else with to any
kind of recusal um when it comes before
the legislature it's always if it's
greater than for you whatever interest
you have whatever profession you may
have or whatever volunteer effort you
may have on a particular board that's
where the difference comes repres
represent tyy said that very explicitly
thank
you thank you representative W uh
representative C
thank you Mr chair um I know we have
some subs here and we've already
discussed this many times in committee
before so we're going back many times so
it would be nice and I I'll be honest
that I think we should take an ethics
class two or three times a year because
it's it's just so I don't want to say
divisive but it's so something we need
to keep on top of our
mind thank you representative sers
further discussion
okay I'm going to take a two-minute
break here for a second uh there's a
question of whether um whether
OSS flipped the
um Amendment numbers so hold on just a
second could we do it could we discuss
both
AMS
can can we get back
to can we come back to the real world
here
yeah
yeah little
help I don't think she heard you I think
I
don't
so
so representative
costal so what um in further examination
of
the of the um two amendments we actually
had before
us um we brought one up for for
conversation and that was um ending in
H
um there were actually two amendments
brought to OS um the other ended in
0693 h
um they have taken pieces of one and and
not carried them forward into the other
so uh there's just
enough if it was um simply a case of the
the percentage number one and five I
would have continued on and just said
everyone understand that we're changing
that to one and and still vote on it and
then we changed the one and go from
there but but there's actually a section
that whole section not just the
percentage but the entire section is
missing so I think what I'm going to do
is uh recess to a Time certain which
would be next week um reconcile the two
numbers reconcile the two bills and
bring it back to um to us exact next
week at the same
time any any yes representative wall
thank you very
much
um that uh the chairman is correct in
the error that has occurred and the
Ethics Committee is leaning towards
uh the um
0693 with that language in it that was
left out so hopefully when we recess
these get Blended together and we can
vote for it at our next meeting thank
you Mr chairman and in the meantime just
as
a pot sweetener here um we will make
sure that we ask um Ethics Committee um
for their views on some of the issues
that were brought up today um one being
the municipal
um um positions that some legislators
hold representative W Mr chairman um the
Ethics Committee will not be meeting but
I will be in touch with the members and
get that message back to you thank you
great thank you representative wall um
so with that I am uh
recessing um House Bill
1388 um
to next
Wednesday and I haven't watched the
calendar um but I have uh not put the
schedule in for next week but it should
be next
Wednesday um and we will only we've done
all of our hearings so it would just be
an exact session that we would have that
day okay so we're um recessing 1388 till
um Wednesday one week hence
uh now give us just a minute and we'll
be going on to House Bill uh
okay representative
mcarter um we will be opening the
executive session on House Bill
1030 recognize representative Sheen for
a motion yes thank you Mr chair I move a
to
pass representative Sheen moves ought to
pass uh is the there a
second representative mcarter seconds um
the bill is open to further Amendment
representative she
and yes I'd like to move amendment
number
d558 and I'm going to pass out to you
right
now did you on that way
too representative she and moves um
Amendment
z558 H um representative Sheen would you
like to speak to
that
yes
okay
okay no
uh um um so um the original Bill uh
hb130
[Music]
um was drafted as a placeholder bill um
representative wall and I were appointed
to the special committee on commissions
by the speaker to look over inactive uh
commissions and committees and uh repeal
those that are inactive and uh the
original sb84 that came to our committee
um was held to use as a vehicle to amend
with the findings that we came up with
in the special committee on
commissions um that bill unanimously
passed this committee and the house and
is currently in the other
body where it hasn't been acted on
yet
so to make sure sure that it is um taken
up by the other body we used hb130 and
amended our sb84 language that we passed
recently into the bill so it will go to
the other body where it will be looked
at that's what this amendment is thank
you representative Shen uh just to
clarify one little Point um s SP
84 was amended by this um by the house
and sent back
um it the other body on the other side
of the wall um can either concur non-c
concur or ask for a committee of
conference um there may
be we have no indication what they plan
to do however
if we send this bill over um amended
with the same language there would have
to be a hearing in the Senate on this
bill um so it's not going to it would it
would have to be taken up and that's
basically what uh representative Sheen
had so this is um even though I hate the
phrase this is the belt and suspenders
approach um we're giving them two bites
at the same Apple so um with that is
there any other
discussion representative Lane um thank
you is is this a gerine
Amendment
yes thank you for your help
representative re any further
discussion seeing none I will ask the
clerk to call the
role Ah that's right um so this is a
vote on the amendment only um I was
there a mo a motion in a second was that
did that happen oh you did okay yes we
moved that
um I was on the amendment on the OTP we
did but on the amendment yes
sorry so we have moved and seconded the
amendment um we are going to vote on
accepting Amendment
H and I'll ask the clerk to call the
rooll on that Amendment for
OTP
yes yes yes yes
on the amendment roll call on the
amendment if you vote Yes you accept the
amendment is Mr chair representative
okay calling the rooll on
OTP a no on the amendment
0558 right
H representative Sheen Vice chair Shen
yes representative costable yes clerk
votes yes representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tyy yes representative
sers yes representative wall
yes representative Brenan yes
representative turot yes representative
Richards yes representative Lane yes
representative
cert yes representative Reed yes
representative payer yes and Mr chair
yes
um we have a unanimous acceptance of the
Amendment we now are working on
otpa on um House
Bill house buillt excuse
me excuse
me thank you um we have an otpa on House
Bill
1030 um further discussion
on a to pass as
amended seeing none I will ask the clerk
to call all the
roll I don't think I
do there's
nothing okay otpa motion on
10:30 representative Vice chair Shen yes
representative cable yes clerk votes yes
representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tney yes representative s
yes representative wall representative
Brennan yes representative turot yes
represent thank you representative
Richards yes representative Lane yes
representative Sebert yes representative
Reed yes representative payer yes and Mr
chair yes okay unanimous 16 y
representative Pearson moves consent
without
objection consent it is
uh be
a five minute break here uh before we
take out house bill um
1629 if I could ask the Republicans to
meet me in the back
office could you tell me
who
okay we're
back
um the chair uh we are taking up a exec
session on House Bill
1629 uh chair recognizes is
representative Sheen for a motion yes I
move interim study on HB 1629 chair
moves interim study uh is there second
seconded by I saw representative s's
hand first um
discussion seeing
none
um I will just say um 1629 9 is the bill
uh for those people that weren't here um
1629 is a bill that uh requires the
Attorney General to
notify um the speaker and Senate
President when they have probable cause
to believe someone a
representative is uh or Senator is not
um in
District
um it opens up an enormous number number
of questions from that point on um some
of which uh are dealing with um the fact
that there's a blank in the in the
legislation of what what's supposed to
happen with that knowledge um does the
does the Senate President or the um or
the speaker if they are conducting an
investigation their own are they are
they supposed to stop that investigation
as is what happens within our own Ethics
Committee um when they hear of an
investigation they stop investigating
themselves um are conversely are the
Senate President and speaker supposed to
start investigating on their own um the
bill is silent on that um if in fact
they do their own investigation and they
reach a conclusion and then that
conclusion happens to be different than
what the Attorney General's
um um investigation turns out what
happens then no one the bill is silent
um there's also the question right off
the bat um of what happens if the
Attorney
General doesn't want this type of um
action um they we don't this is this is
um
this is a procedure that's happening
within the house so you need to
recognize that we're actually um
crossing the separation of powers at
this point um and generally the Attorney
General doesn't like
disclosing um any investigations even up
to and including U the grand jury um
they very rarely if ever um announced
that anyone is under investigation so
this this is a this is a lot of
questions um to me it demands interim
study I will be voting in favor of
interim study um uh there's just there's
just too many unanswered questions here
um so for that reason I will be voting
interim study and if there's no further
discuss up representative Reed thank you
Mr chair this is an issue I've been here
this is my fourth term I I this is an
issue that comes up every single term it
not just this term quite famously but
every single term I've been here there
has been a member that apparently was
not living in their district and that is
unconstitutional legal I think we have
to do something about it and while I
concede that um perhaps there could be
stronger language I think this is a step
in the right direction so I would like
to see it ought to
pass thank you representative Reed
representative sers thank you Mr chair
and and again I I I don't think
anybody's saying this doesn't have Merit
and like representative Reed just said I
mean every year I it's definitely a
problem but I I think you got to get the
language right we got to make sure it's
almost perfect because so many times
there's been so many holes and languages
and just one word you know and it causes
us turmoil and we can't solve a problem
which should be very clear so I think
this in stud is the best way to go to
get this it out Al
together thank you representative cers
representative Pearson I think I saw
thank you Mr chair I I have a question
um con concerning the procedural part of
this perhaps you can you can help me
here uh the Attorney General shall
notify the presiding officer the
minority leader and and the clerk of the
relevant chamber what happens if that
person is the one being
investigated since this is a this is
forcing a procedure uh thank you for
your question I I assume that was a
question to the chair um I have no idea
um the bill is silent on that point um
um it it it is another of in a long line
of questions of what happens if the
actual investigation is one of those
people that they are notifying I don't
know um so again it uh it lends itself
to interim study further
discussion
seeing none clerk will call the
role okay on the motion of interim study
for HB
1629 uh chair Sheen I'm sorry whoops uh
Vice chair Sheen
yes representative costable yes clerk
votes yes representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tney yes representative
sers yes representative
wall representative Brennan no
Representative
turot no representative Richards
representative Lane no representative
cert no representative Reed no
representative payer no and the chair
yes 8 to8 vot is 8 to8 interim study
fails
chair would entertain another motion
representative payer I would like to
move a to pass chair uh representative
payer moves out to pass is it seconded
second seconded by representative Reed
forther
discussion seeing
none clerk will call a
role on the motion of ought to
pass 1629 uh Vice chair Sheen no
Representative costable no repres uh
clerk votes no representative Pearson no
Representative mcarter no Representative
tney no Representative sers
no representative wall yes
representative oh sorry I ran out of
pre-filled out sheets Brandon
yes representative
turot yes representative Richards yes
representative Lane yes representative
Sebert yes representative Reed yes
representative payer
yes and Mr chair
no in a shocking turn of events it's
even uh o to pass fails
um anyone want to try for interim
study I'm sorry um anyone I thank you uh
Mr chair I move in expedient to
legislate uh representative costable
moves um in expedient to legislate is
there SEC seconded by representative
mcarter any
discussion seeing
none clerk will call the role on the
motion of I HB 1629 Vice chair Sheen yes
representative costable yes clerk votes
yes representative Pearson yes
representative mcarter yes
representative tney yes representative
sers yes representative wall
representative Brennan
no Representative turot
no
representative sorry Lane oh Richards
sorry sorry
no uh representative Lane no
representative cert no representative
Reed no representative payer no
and Mr chair
yes my math says 8 to8 which means no
recommendation um motion going to I'm
assuming
motion um held by is going to be opop
passed is that the motion that you it's
automatically
op is that are you writing a on
o okay you're right so by tomorrow great
is there time by
tomorrow you want me to get it to you
noon noon or representative she and
either one
um I don't think I have any other
information for you um we
have um I did I did wasn't on this list
but was
1479 on the calendar for today no okay
good all right um I'm I think we're done
for the day unless there's any other
information anybody has for me seeing
none uh watch the calendar thank
you